all right so this is against all legal
advice before i start i want to say that
i would never in a million years on
purposely intentionally try to harm take
advantage or scam i've been investing in
a lot of cryptocurrency lately and milf
it's insane guys i 25 x my investment to
think i would participate in a rug pool
that has my face on it it's kind of like
saying you know hey uh i'm going to go
and rob a bank without wearing a mask
and it's moon portal is out right now
guys you can swipe up and check it out
just doesn't make any sense he just
can't stop contradicting himself as
you'll see in the next clip too i am no
crypto mastermind so let's start here
with all of my wallets and transactions
on save the kids and there's a wallet
that i have that nobody knows about but
i also want to say that i am genuinely
so sorry that any of this ever happened
and i feel terrible that anybody was
affected even though i was tricked by
somebody that took advantage of me i'd
take full responsibility for that and i
really want to apologize about being led
by somebody that i should not have
trusted so much and for this i hold my
hands up don't get me wrong i'm not
looking for any sympathy my life is
falling apart i've been kicked from
phase and he just refused to take any
accountability for any of